today I want to talk about captures
capturing and trades how many of you
like to capture your opponent's pieces
yeah isn't that the funnest I love to
capture my opponent's pieces sometimes
all the capture is as a trade I take my
opponents queen he takes my queen
so it's even-steven trade right wrong
many many times in chess the capture or
the trade favors one side or the other
somebody benefits from a trade and I
want to show you how and why okay so
let's begin with an example let's say
that white plays this move before let's
say that black plays this move e5 so far
it's pretty even right let's say White's
not so clever and he plays d3 this move
blocks in his bishop and that's why we
don't think that move is very clever it
is black develops a knight and white
develops a bishop black develops a
bishop so so far nothing special has
happened nothing special at all
whatsoever it's just normal normal stuff
and remember what I said I loved to
capture my opponent's pieces I just
thought that was the greatest thing and
oftentimes I would make this mistake
I would capture my opponent's Knight and
I would think to myself he recaptured my
bishop
and I wasn't interested in what stayed
on the board what I was excited about
was what left the board I thought this
was three to three this is an even trade
on the material yes but was this a good
trade for white no why not why isn't
this a good trade for white exactly
right first of all we gonna go back just
one little simple move ago at this
moment the black queen is sleeping
it hasn't developed and after this trade
suddenly the black queen is awake black
is ahead in development one two four
white one two three four black so black
leads and development and he's attacking
the pawn on f2 just what you said you
said it perfectly right so this trade
actually worked out really good for
black okay we're gonna go back we're
going to go back I'm going to set up a
little bit of situations I'm going to
set up situation isn't it
I'm going to ask you if the trades are
good or bad for one side let's say
whites very clever and he plays here and
black plays a developing move as well
white brings his Bishop to g2 so the
bishop is on the long diagonal white B
in shadows his bishop now black he
thinks okay all of his pieces are asleep
he brings out his Knight okay and white
says oh I loved
trade I love to trade I will take this
night with my bishop now black
recaptures the bishop with his pond was
this trade good for white yes or no
those who think it was a good trade for
white raise your hand those who think is
a good trade for black raise your hand
okay it was a good trade for black why
we go back just a moment ago in the time
count the score is 2 to 2 right 2 to 2
it's pretty simple now after this trade
occurs now what's the time count young
man but black has double pawns that is
true that the time count is 2 to 1 in
favor of black that trade helped our
opponent uh-huh ok let's continue and
let's say that in this position white
plays this move Knight of three black
plays this move Knight f6 white plays
this move D to default notice that the
pieces and pawns are getting into
conflict with one another white is
playing in the center and so is black so
far both players have followed good
general opening principles now black
decides to take this pawn fair enough
and we have a trait pawn for pawn pawn
for pawn pretty good in this situation
how many think this trade favors white
how many think the trade favored black
how many think that this trade was about
even-steven that neither side really had
a big benefit I'm with the third group I
think that this trade was a bit
like even-steven so that both sides did
well so at the moment that the way that
we determine who gets favored by a trait
and you really should think about this
when you make a trade or you make a
capture is who benefits
at this moment what's the score in the
time count one two three one two - but
it's blacks move so black could catch up
on the time count so at the moment it's
three to two black to play now let's
imagine black captures the night okay so
now we're very excited the Queen
recaptures who which side benefited the
most from this trade white if you think
white benefit it raise your hand you
think black benefited raise your head
okay for those of you who thought it was
white congratulations
white benefited why what's the time
count now one two three one now let us
make a different move for black from
them let we let us say black plays ePHI
whoo that attacks our night we better be
really really careful now if we don't
move our night it's going to be captured
it's gonna be captured by that bomb
that's bad bad bad bad why not why not
if we take the black knight on c6 pawn
takes and what's the result it's a trade
it's a fair trade right night for night
and that was two blacks benefit just
because we lose a little bit of time
just because we lose a little battle one
once and that once it again doesn't mean
we lose the game what we're just
trying to do right now is to understand
who benefits from trades okay so this is
a trade that I think could benefit black
mmm okay so let's just go back for a
moment to this position and let's say
black makes a new move he decides to
advance his pawn he doesn't do it to
squares he doesn't want so it's one two
three yeah one two three
and white decides to go c4
just as an example okay now I want to
think about this question because it's
going to come up real fast black he sees
that his Bishop can come into the game
with a check do you see how that vicious
can develop a check yeah yeah yeah yeah
pretty good now black does play this
move Bishop f8 to b4 check to White's
King white blocks the check with his
bishop now think about this situation
for a second because it suddenly got
exciting how many see that the white
knight on d4 can be captured whoo and
that Bishop on d2 can be captured
can black win a piece
yeah how many things black can win a
piece pretty good
how many think No pretty good how could
black win a piece who's got an idea how
this black when a piece young man how
does black win a piece
so does this win up is this the idea
that everybody had that Knight takes d4
wins a piece for black it doesn't win a
piece because the bishop would retake
the bishop now let's stop for a second
what just happened black one a knight
white one a bishop this trade is even in
the material count 3 2 3 who benefits
let's see 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 so at the moment
white is still ahead in the time count
but do you notice something this Knight
is under attack by the Queen did you
also notice that this bishop oh it stops
black from castling yes young man what
do you think and white is going to
castle one of the key key elements an
opening strategy is King safety I can't
tell you how many guy times I got
checkmated did you know I just gave a
class the lecture before and then that
lecture the class checkmated me i played
badly and I got checkmated and one of
the key opening principles is to get
your King into safety castle this trade
favors white ok now let's go back to
this moment and let's say black plays
Bishop takes check and white trades
plays Queen
eggs D 2 equal on the material but who
benefited who benefited from the trade
young man in the iron why why did white
get the better of the deal why yeah not
exactly the answer how many think that
white benefited you made a good trade
for white who could tell me why white
benefited so after the result of this
operation we have one two three four
five one two three white increased his
lead in the time count and now he's
ahead five to three so this whole trade
remember I used I said how I love to
capture my opponents pieces I started to
realize that it's not always good to
just go ahead and play four trades
traded the bishops
so Bishop comes here yes and the Queen
okay cool let's think about that
recapturing with the knight is excellent
it's simply excellent because it helps
us in our time count one two three four
five but it has one small detail that's
a problem what's the problem
that's the problem we leave our night we
leave our night on pre do you guys know
what unfreeze means night on pries
hanging on priests on priests is a
French expression it means in capture
you left the night on pretty your left
the night in capture which is why we
recaptured with the Queen okay we're
gonna continue this for just a second
this this line and black does not give a
check instead black plays Bishop attacks
the night mmm Bishop attacks the night
mm-hmm
young man what do you think yes pond the
III is an excellent turn because not
only does it defend the night it also
brings another of our army our team into
play white didn't do that why didn't do
that white decided to play Knight b5
whoo you know why what white decided
that move how many can guess young men
why did white play Knight b5 yes well
yeah exactly he white maybe he's right
we don't know yet maybe White's right
maybe White's thinking that if black
blows it makes a mistake like this he
could move his knight check and win a
rook oh that would be juicy no so why
play Knight here hoping for a mistake a
fault by the opponent let's say black
plays the move a six attacking the
knight young man
yeah correct the white knight could move
to d6 with a check against the king how
many like that move Shaq is cool right
very good
now black he could take the knight and
trade bishop for night and then the
queen takes now based only only on the
time count think about this for a moment
what do you guys think about King to e7
think about that that move King to e7
whoo yeah are you and what do you think
is that a good move for black why true
but from the time count perspective
let's count exactly at this moment it's
one help me to and for white
now black to turn its blacks ahead how
many of you would like to play Knight on
d6 capture c8 check how many is that a
good move
not a good move from from the time cap
no that would be the terror that would
be great for black why at the end of
this trade although the trade is even
who benefited let's count again
for black whoa now our young said yes
your name whoo that's where we're wrong
we always count whatever is not on its
original square although we have this
situation white now castles okay so that
adds to one two three four five you
could say the white king isn't doing too
much on g1 but no no the white king is
saved now our gem made a very good point
that although blacks ahead in the time
count
he can't be too proud of this King his
King is in the center right right so
let's do it again so now we go one two
three four five one two three four five
six seven so let's see what if black
were clever he would want to get his
King out of danger so let's say I play
this move what is it now one two three
four five six seven eight okay and let's
say white plays Knight to c3 one two
three four five six now remember what
argument saying that you can't Castle
black puts his King back into safety
he's going to go in front of his pawn
children yeah we also say castling by
hand so so far we're just trying to
understand what which side benefits from
trades and which sides does not okay so
now the position is black has everybody
developed except for his queen this
pawns are a good pawn shield for him so
we're just going to stop this and we're
going to go back to this
guarding position and I want how many of
you have ever heard of the Queens gambit
accepted Queens get what you guys are
pretty good very very sophisticated I
want to say that you guys know the
Queens gambit accepted okay so one of
the things that I I want to talk about
is gambit play okay and the idea of
gambits is I give I sacrifice a pawn
maybe two maybe three pawns in order to
get a lead in the time count so let me
just give you an example so this is
called the queen pawn opening because
the pawn in front of the Queen advances
this is called the queen pawn defense
because when white makes a move it's
called an opening move when black makes
some opening move it's called the
defensive move so queen pawn opening
queen pawn defense white plays this move
offering a sacrifice our young what as
defense or opening as white and do you
play the Queens gambit also okay so
white offers black the opportunity to
capture and what's the idea the idea is
that if the pawn is captured white
starts to think to himself gosh if I
could recapture that pawn I'm going to
be ahead in the time count
yes England play efore okay so now at
the moment it's one two two one yes play
E for now I'm black yes
III is also possible you it defends the
pawn on d4 but you know it's a funny
thing you're the general of your army
right and as the general of your army
you got to talk to all the troops you
got to ask them are they happy so when
you played the move III did you talk to
your bishop on c1 did you ask him what
he thought about that move okay as it
turns out III is a major move and so is
efore I just wanted to show this example
of how the gambit works black is very
happy because black 1upon but white is
threatening to recapture the pawn so
let's say black would make a terrible
move here not good then after Bishop
takes c4 what's the time count 3-1 right
Wow how did white why did white get such
a jump
why did white get so far ahead in the
time count how did that it was just it's
just a few moves and whites already way
ahead Arjun why did that happen
one way of the way I would say it is as
follows I would say it like this white
moved his pawn one time black moved his
pawn one time black moved white moved
his pawn once black moved his pawn twice
and then that pawn that moved twice was
captured and that was where black lost
time he moved his pawn twice and it was
captured so it's one two three now
instead of a bad move like this terrible
terrible does this move play in the
center by
it does nothing for the center let's say
black he's very clever very ambitious
very ambitious black said hey man I'm
upon ahead I want to keep the part I
will protect the pawn margin a for very
very good move
so with this okay first of all black
says I want to protect the pond so I
defend the pond with beef i White says
ok I'll attack the pawn that's defending
this pawn ok so let's do it like this
for just a second let's imagine that
what black captures this punk Queen
takes a four check or Bishop takes c4
and what is happening one two three one
very good that's terrible for black yes
you men and block yeah that's exactly
right
putting that King into check will force
black to block and possibly lose time
let's say black says I want to defend
the pawn how many think that was a good
move
no it's not because after I capture is
this pawn in a pin the rook with wood
okay so that was the wrong move instead
we're going to play c7 c6 now the pawns
defendant how many people like blacks
position
how many people like White's position
still unclear still unclear at the
moment whites upon down what do you see
okay we'll come to b3 in just a moment
first we'll preface
b2 b3 white decides to capture the pawn
on b5 and black makes the recapture okay
so at the moment the score is two to two
but how many of you think White's rook
is developed how many of you think
White's rook isn't moved so therefore
it's not developed okay now I want to
play
Arjun's move oh really good move b2 b3
this pawn attacks this pawn
okay now I want you to imagine what
would happen don't all shout at once
c4 takes b3 we'll stop for a moment and
we notice is white down behind two ponds
white has made a gambit we call that a
gambit of two ponds and hit currently
the score is 1 2 2 2 but it's white to
play what do you think excellent but
it's Bishop f1 captures pawn on d5 so
that was goodbye white bishop on f1
captures pawn on d5 with check 1 2 3 2 1
Bishop d7 what do you think young man
now what would you do sorry we would
trade okay very good very good done
let's just think about this for a second
it's white to play now if white plays
Bishop takes d7 check which side would
benefit from that trade young man what
do you think why
correct
so Bishop takes d7 check is okay but
that's a trade that might benefit black
yes mmm what's better move than Bishop
takes brilliant most important it
defends the bishop so Queen on d1
captures b3 which defends the bishop and
now what's the time count Wow
that happened fast White's way ahead
four to one in the time count holy cow
black really blew it right according to
our time count analysis white is so far
ahead in position we say white has a big
advantage let's continue the trades for
just a second Bishop takes b5 check what
do you do beef b5 check one two three
nothing okay now here's the question I
want to pose should white trade Queens
should white trade Queens and man what
do you think yes because
very good so what would be white best
move
what's White's best move yeah are you
Queen daddy 3 would that increase your
time count okay what do you think I love
this move Knight to c3 1 2 3 4 1 now if
black trades Queens who benefits who
benefits in there because and very good
so today's lecture is all about make be
conscious ask yourself a question when
you make a trade ask yourself am i
helping my opponent or is it or my
opponent helping me and use the time
count as a way of determining the answer
thank you for coming I'm sorry to say an
adult turn them into starting now so the
door we gotta go bye bye have a good
weekend